happy happy Monday everybody ah yeah I
know I feel that way too
you know if I were sitting where you
were I'd be just as excited
what a great weekend now once again we
all got to visit the strangest place in
the universe you know that place where
people actually think Bill Nye is a
scientist Pete Davidson's a sex symbol
and and joy is a place called Behar
talk about America's mainstream media a
world run by conjurers who believe they
could hypnotize us into not believing
what we see you know we've been here
before remember this gem from back in
2020 to the same Among Us it looked like
a bunch of thugs setting fire to a city
while Democrat Mayors hid behind the
toppled statues but to the media it
looked like a friendly game of spin the
bottle
a bottle filled with gas later to be lit
and tossed into a business
remember when the media called Summer
2020 the summer of love maybe so if
you're dating the Zodiac Killer
don't knock it
was a hell of a kisser but now
but now they're back that adorable bunch
of miscreants known as the mostly
peaceful CNN presents it's mostly
peaceful featuring Molotov cocktails
public beatings burning buildings
looting and shooting but no worries it's
mostly peaceful people die people lose
their businesses cities suffer millions
in Damages it's CNN's mostly peaceful
tonight's episode antifa goes to Atlanta
[Music]
foreign
landed the city had begun building a
police training facility you know the
place that offers the better training
for law enforcement that the left's
always been demanding where cops can
learn to defend themselves from a six
foot five 280 pound career criminal
trying to stab them to death uh by
reading a poem to him from Maya Angelou
of course the true face of defund
emerged right on cue the anti-cop rally
rabble descended on the site to occupy
it and last week the police attempted to
clear them out so construction could
continue and of course rioting broke out
or what CNN calls a harmless pillow
fight
seven people arrested on charges of
domestic Terror a cop was shot when
police returned fire the shooter a
non-binary protester was killed even
before police asked for pronouns
I wonder does reporting that the
casualty was non-binary caused twice as
much outrage because of course Mass
outrage was the response after antifa
Thug's call put out a call online for a
night of rage on Saturday a horde
descended on downtown Atlanta throwing
rocks and molotovs at police smashing
windows and lighting police cars on fire
tourists tried to find flights to a
safer destination but Ukraine was closed
for the night
now after the mayor held depressor
saying the city wouldn't tolerate this
violence here's what CNN had to say I
think that there's a real
blurring of the lines in the use of the
word violence
is property destruction violence um to
some people it certainly is you keep
using these words violent violent
violent violent the only acts of
violence against people that I saw were
actually police tackling protesters can
we stop with the violent word I mean the
violence is okay but but stop using the
word
so it was a peaceful night of Rage which
I guess is just like a wacky outbreak of
monkey pox
but it's good to see CNN no longer
traffics in radical left-wing ideology
anymore what that was so CNN calls this
non-violent just as they're closing
their historic Atlantic location they're
moving
something doesn't jive generally you
don't flee a city in a U-Haul if you
actually believe it's safe
but it just shows that despite all the
Bloodshed that came from their enabling
coverage for years CNN has still learned
nothing they keep making the same
mistake over and over again like when I
give too much money to charity
but CNN isn't the only one here's ABC
News this take
if you can read that there's that same
phrase again it's just a peaceful
protest that happened to turn violent
you know it happened to turn Violet see
it's out of their hands how did this
happen it's like a tiger cub that goes
crazy on a talk show and eats Brian
kilmeade's face
you have that dream too don't you
and so our cities are turning into hell
holes and we're not supposed to notice
it's like when Brit Hume steals office
supplies we're told to look the other
way
he can't help it they say Atlanta
Philadelphia SF here in New York where
D.A Alvin Bragg claims his reforms will
stop skyrocketing Subway crime our own
Fox News weatherman Adam klotz was just
jumped on the subway by a gang after he
tried to defend an older man being
harassed by the group
they beat him like he got the forecast
wrong on the day they were supposed to
go looting
laughs
lucky for him he clots
I know
cops caught three of them all teens no
criminal charges were filed and they
were released to their parents
with criminal justice like that it's
safer to ride the Subway on the outside
but Urban Decay isn't new from the 60s
to the 90s our cities look like they've
been sacked by cranky Visigoths people
fled in droves the only institution left
that actually functioned was the mafia
it's happening again though but this is
different because we're told there's
nothing to see here it's not happening
just like the Border just like the
documents just like the elections so
what are the same Among Us go then so
how about Mexico they never finish that
wall right they're all coming here so
let's just switch countries right we get
tequila they get Don Lemon
let's welcome
tonight's guest he so well dressed his
pocket square has a pocket square most
of making money on Fox Business Charles
space
this correspondent survived the most
dangerous war zone of all the Real
Housewives of Orange County author of
the new book Chasey catastrophe Rick
sexy Lemon Ball
and she's always there in a clutch
because
she's contributor tattoo
[Applause]
and and he's like a Life Alert button
he provides excellent protection and old
women want to put him in their showers
[Music]
[Applause]
it's funny because it's true yeah I did
write that one yeah
that was a good one all right Charles uh
when these people are talking about how
it's not violent they're obviously not
factoring in what happens to these small
businesses or the small business owners
the minority owners and stuff like that
how did they not learn how did they not
learn from the last three years well
first of all that dude we heard I I get
a feeling he's never been on the train
yeah certainly not a New York City train
and he's never probably been jumped I
mean this it's so I don't even get like
who who are they talking to they're even
their own Echo chamber yeah has to be
getting smaller and smaller because this
is so nonsensical I mean just but the
news itself the mainstream media has
just gone so far off kilter it's really
nuts I mean it's obviously when
something is burning up okay when
someone throws a Molotov cocktail when
someone goes to the hospital what
bothers me though is that this small
anti these anarchists get to go from
City to city and Spark these things and
get cover yeah from the mainstream media
that is really a shame yeah it's true
it's like they built them up is because
they're anti assets but all they are
very miserable and quite unattractive
Caucasians they're not very they're very
ugly people they keep searching well a
lot of them feel like they can't get
laid a lot of them feel like they were
in a drug drug therapy like you know
they were on some sort of drug and I I'm
with you on that one yeah I think
they're like a step away from Mass
Killing Type people because uh they're
like they're there's there's a narcope
issue there's a family issue there's
they're the opposite of Rick Leventhal
yeah you brought some you brought some
fans with you I might have brought one
or two yeah yeah yeah
Rick it's great to see you Sue red eye
back in the days of fox you haven't aged
a bit thank you I'm getting younger
actually I think you are you have this
great book out chasing catastrophe it's
about your life covering Wars and
hurricanes and many other things that
can't be mentioned the problem with your
book though Rick is there's no uh
there's no index yeah well you're not in
it Greg so you can stop looking for
yourself
I mean sorry it's the whole point so
what do you when you're looking at this
I I a lot of people when they read them
when they leave cable news they leave
and they don't look back yeah yeah which
I think you might have done but what do
you make of this when they when they
were still are calling violent protests
peaceful well I think it's it's awful I
I've seen this repeat itself over and
over again and actually before I left
Fox I would report on this every night
on on the the non-violent violent
protest yes but I didn't call them
non-violent protests they because they
were violent and that obviously is
violence and for them to try to
perpetuate this ridiculous position that
oh well no one's getting hurt or it's
just prob it's just property damage it's
not real violence it's ridiculous and
the other piece of it is that they're
enabling the behavior by not Prosecuting
the people who are responsible for it so
it feeds on itself if you know you're
going to get away with it you're going
to do it again tomorrow and we've seen
that time and time again you can't let
people break the law and go free or
they're going to keep breaking the law
and they're going to escalate yeah no
it's true well it's put thanks Kat I
hope you were listening I hope you
learned something from him
um let's talk about for our very own our
very own poor Adam clots I mean if it
was kill Mead I wouldn't care
uh do CA you know he's been around a
while but a poor Young Adam clocks
weatherman probably can't fight no
no it's okay he did you see his tweet
what he tweeted and he said well the
headline I just read viciously beaten by
teens is true it's doing way more damage
to my ego than the physical beating did
but I mean he has like a sense of humor
about this horrible thing that happens
he is living the thing that every God
but I would say every guy has in the
subway whether they have to make a
choice to intervene or not and like if
you're if you're like a person if you're
there and you're going like okay I could
die or I could live the rest of my life
thinking I didn't do something you see
let's say a woman's getting slapped
around by a dude and you don't step in
but then that guy just stabs you you're
dead but if you didn't get stabbed and
you're not dead you're gonna go like wow
I'm a wuss yeah so he was I give him
Kudos first going up but who never go to
a group of teens they're like rabid
finches oh yeah I
well that's why I think it's so
interesting that this comment of you
know uh destroying property isn't
violence and then taking it further and
saying destroying properties you know is
not the same as violence against a human
is anybody saying that it is yeah I
don't think and of course the interview
doesn't doesn't ask that like who are
these people who are saying that it's
the same because they don't exist right
but I think it's actually that same side
that is you know diminishing
humanity and human life and safety
because they don't care when stuff like
that happens which I think we should all
be able to agree on is bad it is bad it
is bad what did you make of the atom
clots okay well I think what you're
trying to say is that a coward dies a
thousand deaths you know what soldier
does I came up with that yes I think
that's where you were I came up with
that in a really bad way that's what you
were trying to say
my as taken from a guy who's been in a
fight who's been outnumbered most of the
fights I've been in you don't announce
it that would be my advice to him in the
future swing first make an example of
the first one so the other ones go oh
sh you know but when you say hey take
your hands off that guy yeah that's
that's the wrong side of white privilege
that's the mistake okay that's if if if
for nothing else don't investigate and
don't announce okay because then they
and then they see that's the movies with
him yeah he didn't they turned around
and they were expecting a showdown they
were like get him you know he was like
whoa he thought he was gonna have some
dialogue no you gotta but but okay if he
if he'd walked over and punched one of
the 15 year olds the headlight would be
Fox weatherman storm front yes angry
French yeah saved old men from group of
teams no you know what but good for him
he did the right thing yeah and I'm and
I'm glad that he's able to talk about it
yeah so that's let's
he did do the right thing but he paid a
heavy price for it yeah no but and
that's when that since I brought up the
white thing that's when white people
interfering is a good thing now you go
down to Atlanta where these privileged
trust funds come in through black
neighborhoods and burn the place down
and then they leave yes yeah and then
the neighborhoods are destroyed and I
don't understand how a Don Lemon or
someone can't be going these racist
people using plight to hurt black
communities because that's who they're
hurting that's where they're they're
destroying our neighborhoods
for no other reason than for just to do
it yeah there's no such thing as that's
like saying mostly alive you're either
breathing or you're not it's either
peaceful or it's violent and these are
violent and who gets hurt when a
building burns down everybody in that
neighborhood jobs other business why
would they come in Atlanta used to be a
booming City it was it was growing now
it's not because of stuff like this
mayor
arrest these don't let those six go hit
them with everything you can to send
some kind of message yeah you're not
going to get invited to the to the
Grammys and all other kind of stuff but
your neighborhoods will be safer hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else